400 trillion to 1 the odds of becoming a
human being you choose what you're
looking for because what you look for
you find that's how [ __ ] life works
you know being successful takes several
different variables
I think self-awareness is number one if
you don't know yourself and you don't
know what you're good at you've got no
shot because you're gonna be spinning
your wheels I think work ethic is at the
top nobody nobody watching this right
now knows anybody that's successful at
all that hasn't put in serious amounts
of work very quickly I can tell you you
need to get every voice out of your head
besides yourself and you need to love
yourself you will win can't live your
life based on other people's point of
view I am tired of people not starting
and living their life on one very simple
thing which is they're worried about
what other people think
learn the work ethic and the skills that
match your ambition you get to live life
one time and this is the time right now
to understand what's actually happening
and actually map your behavior to
something that will impact you for the
next 80 years pay the [ __ ] attention to
who's giving you the advice who's giving
the advice and more importantly if you
live your life where you're comfortable
taking somebody else's point of view on
how you should [ __ ] live your life you
deserve to figure out what you [ __ ]
puts you on fire and you're halfway
decent map I'd become tunnel [ __ ]
vision I only want one thing for people
that I have really outside of health the
only thing I wish for people is them to
love what they do as much as I do
you can't it's that you're not willing
to give up Daanish [ __ ] for a better
light it's very very simple put yourself
in a position to succeed figure out who
you really are and figure out if what
you're talking is being mapped by what
you're doing because the second you put
those things together [ __ ] [ __ ]
unlocks whose permission are you looking
for go to June you're thin you're gonna
die if nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] when
you die
why the [ __ ] you worrying about their
opinions while you're alive
I just can't explain to everybody like
clearer when you figure out who you are
and be all that you win regardless of
what you're trying to accomplish you've
got to tell the world about it this is
now the world you're not betting on this
your finished if you're not betting on
this you're finished if you're not
betting on this you're finished